welcome back to CBS mornings we told you
earlier that Michael fanone who almost
died defending the U.S Capitol on
January 6 2021 secretly recorded his
conversations with lawmakers in the
months that followed this photo shows
the D.C metropolitan police officer just
after he got an electrical shock on his
neck and before he was beaten with a
flagpole he suffered Burns he suffered a
heart attack
and a traumatic brain injury after
Riders assaulted him that day fenone has
since resigned as a police officer and
has criticized those he says are trying
to quote whitewash The Assault on the
Capitol and he's got a new Memoir it's
called Hold the Line the Insurrection
and one cop's battle for America's Soul
it's published by an imprint of Simon
Schuster which like CBS is a part of
Paramount Global uh Michael phenone
joins us now Mike thank you for being
here
um yes for having me of course we
mentioned at the very top and then gave
all the background that you have these
recordings and I want to get to those
but first I I want to focus on where you
were in your life before January 6 and
what you lost you lost your privacy some
of your physical health some of your
mental health
um and and yet you've been very public
about what you experienced and then this
book is a new milestone in that why do
you continue talking about this what's
your mission because it has cost you
greatly
uh well I continue to talk about because
I haven't accomplished what I set out to
accomplish which was accountability for
those that were responsible for January
6th and also for uh acknowledgment for
the officers that fought at the Capitol
that day to preserve democracy
because what you keep saying Michael
over and over again the book tells a lot
of your story but what you really want
people to understand is the truth of
what happened that day you said as a
police officer what you know is there's
no such things as two sets of facts
there's only one set of facts and you've
got evidence to support it yet even some
of your own fellow officers aren't
supporting you in the way that you're
speaking out
yeah I mean that's got to be painful to
you
oh that's the hardest part is the
internal criticism from the law
enforcement Community uh that being said
um
you know I am
deeply grateful for the officers that
were there with me in the lower West
Terrace tunnel and I'm out here trying
to represent them as best I can and make
sure that their sacrifices that day
don't go unnoticed for people who don't
believe with what their own I see in
video uh leading up to the riot on
January 6 and then the day of the riot
itself uh it's it's very hard to
convince them and and almost the more
you try the more they resist
I know you've had conversations with
people where you've experienced that how
do you get through that so as you say
the truth and the accountability you're
looking for becomes a reality
well I mean at first I think I tried by
releasing my body worn camera footage
letting people see firsthand the reality
of the violence of that day
um
you know we're now 19 months later and
unfortunately there's still a large
part of America that either doesn't
believe
uh what happened that day they don't
believe me or they um they're just
indifferent to uh to what happened so
you're a very recognizable guy when
someone stops you at a restaurant or on
a street corner and says hey you're that
guy you're lying you're out there
telling lies how do you handle that
I mean fortunately the in-person
interactions that I've had have been uh
mostly positive that's good
um Norm when I do have negative
interactions the the people are usually
so angry that they're incoherent and I
don't know what the hell they're saying
of course yeah but let's talk about the
the people on Capitol Hill who you were
trying to defend and trying to protect
so you go to meet with the Senators and
the congressmen
um let's talk about the meeting in
Lindsey Graham's office because you were
recording that meeting you had gone
there to do what because what led him to
say you should shoot them in the head I
was my jaw sort of fell open when I read
that although a lot of people thought
that as well I mean it was a common
thought in fact the restraint shown by
officers was significant right what was
going through your head yeah so I mean
I was there that day with Gladys
sicknick who's the mother of Officer
Brian sickness who lost his life as a
result of uh you know his work on
January 6th and also Harry Dunn was with
me and we were there advocating for a
bipartisan commission to investigate the
cause of January 6th just to investigate
yes correct and so we were meeting with
a bunch of senators trying to sway their
vote primarily I think it was all
Republican Senators and Lindsey Graham
happened to be president this one
meeting and during that meeting he um I
don't know if he was trying to be I
don't know like
funny or or what but um you know he did
kind of fly off the handle and say that
uh you know he gave us guns and that he
we should have shot all these protesters
in the head what did you think when he
said that well I told him I thought I
appreciated his enthusiasm uh but you
know there's very specific guidelines
that dictate law enforcement's use of
force and you know while we are
authorized to use deadly force in some
you know very narrow set of
circumstances that it would not have
been practical in that type of an
environment when there are so many
people there condensed in such a small
space yeah there would have been you
know individuals who would have been
just caught in the crossfire and uh and
killed
um without justification
Senator say that to you yeah I mean it
in that
Enviro in that environment yes but it
also speaks to a greater uh
misunderstanding of policing and police
policies you know our politicians are
here to facilitate constructive
conversations about law enforcement with
law enforcement and members of the
community and when you have a sitting
U.S senator doesn't even understand
basic uh police policy right that's a
problem you say that there could be
potential consequences if that day is
whitewashed
um what do you mean by whitewashed and
also what are those consequences
well obviously you have by whitewashing
I'm referring to statements from
lawmakers like Andrew Clyde like
Marjorie Taylor green people who are
saying that either it was not a violent
day
um and you know they do so by taking
taking like a single photograph of you
know a relatively peaceful uh display on
that day and using that micro event to
describe you know the the entire event
in and of itself right
um which is I mean it's not misleading
it's a lie uh you know if two people
hugged it out on the west front of the
Capitol while hundreds of officers are
getting their you know behinds beaten
what uh you know is that an honest
description of of what happened that day
right and obviously if we don't hold
these people accountable
um you know we're going to see this type
of violence again we're going to see
this Playbook uh become a part of our
Nash National politics yeah and when one
side doesn't win they're going to resort
to violence I am so sorry this happened
to you I mean I my heart broke reading
the book it made me angry it made me sad
and I'm thinking you're an officer where
they took where at one point you were
told kill him with his own gun I don't
know how you process that Michael and
continue to do what you what you
continue to do
I'm stubborn
um I mean uh you know when I when I set
my mind on something I mean that's it
and at this point too I mean I took a
huge leap when I resigned from the
police department I mean that's all that
I knew I spent 20 years as a street cop
never sought promotion worked primarily
and I love the job I love the job
narcotics and violent crime and I love
the other officers too and that's what
that's why I responded to the Capitol on
January 6th right it had nothing to do
with anything other than I heard a lot
of officers that were in distress yes
and I went there to support them yeah
and you resigned you weren't ready to
resign but the job they were giving you
would have been five years in a cubicle
or something compared to what you were
doing yeah I'm not a desk uh kind of guy
well you appreciate you said at our desk
yes thank you guys thank you it's really
nice to meet you thank you so much
Michael fanone's book is called Hold the
Line it goes on sale tomorrow wherever
you like to buy your books